Okay, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. now
this is going to be a voicemail that relates
to a lot of online culture stuff.
So if you're like a radio listener or your
watch on free speech TV and you don't know
anything about this, I envy you.
Just give me the next 90 seconds to do this
and then we're going to move on.
There's an online streamer named Steven destiny
Banella the second, he's a personal friend
of mine.
When I was in Los Angeles, we went to dinner
along with a couple other people.
Very nice guy personally.
Uh, he streams a lot of political debates,
video games, whatever.
He's been around for awhile.
I've had him on the show after the democratic
debate last week.
We appeared on each other's channels and we
had a conversation.
Um, a couple of people, including this color
is furious, furious that I appear, as he says,
smitten with destiny.
Take a listen to this.
Hello David.
This is Chuck from California.
Ah, David, David, David.
Come on man.
Why are you smitten with Steven bottle the
second or AKA destiny?
You realize destiny passes.
These, excuse me, throws out these very dismissive
criticisms of progressive and he, he kisses
or is it up to or rather support people like
John Belaney, you listen to some of his arguments.
He's very pro corporate.
He's very anti less anti progressive.
He is anti, um, universal Medicare for all
single payer health care.
Do you not know this about him?
Listen, um, this is just a friend of mine,
right?
I, I have friends and we disagree about abortion.
I have friends and we disagree about God.
I have friends and we disagree about the best
path forward for Medicare.
Um, the idea that, I mean listen is sort of
just a, it's a goof that that's nonsense.
But the idea that there are these purity tests
or check boxes or whatever, I mean, listen,
I don't have friends who are out and out,
white nationalists.
I do have friends from where I, you know,
growing up in high school who have unenlightened
views about race, for example.
Um, people have all sorts of different friends
and acquaintances and this idea that you shouldn't
even talk to people who do this or believe
that or the other thing, uh, you, you know,
the, the, uh, the idea that I'm going to apologize
because I talked to destiny is absolutely
ridiculous and I hope that this type of stuff
doesn't, but I don't really care what parameters
different people use to decide who to associate
with.
I have my parameters and other people might
have others.
My only concern and the reason I bring it
up on the show, even when a lot of people
don't necessarily know who destiny is or care
about this, this issue, um, is that to the
extent that it can affect our removal of Donald
Trump or our ability to win elections in the
Senate and the house at the local level, governor's
mansions, so on and so forth.
That's where I worry about this type of approach.
The, how dare I even be friendly with Steven
Brunel.
He's more pro corporate than I am.
Come on guys, come on.
This is, this is not productive.
Um, we will have today a very special bonus
show where producer Pat will explain what's
going on with the David Pakman show to people
in the audience.
Because today's kind of a weird show in some
ways, and you'll find out about that on the
bonus show.
And then the next week of shows, it's also
going to be strange and bizarre in some ways.
So on today's bonus show, producer Pat will
fill you all in, get instant access.
Did the bonus show by becoming a member@davidpakmandotcomslashmembershiporapatronatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.
[inaudible].